hello everyone and welcome back to the
Women's World Chess Championship second
part of the match being played in
Vladivostok Russia this is game ten and
for those of you who are just tuning in
to win June took the lead in the match
then Agora Chicana equalized and then
immediately garage winner to the lead in
the match so in the previous game in in
game 9 during June I retaliated now the
game is again equal so both of them two
wins all the other games have been grown
and this is game ten now so without
further ado let's check it out and it's
a it's a really really tough theoretical
struggle this one so without further ado
c4 vigor HP not now we have e 6 we have
Knight to c3 d5 and again we transpose
into the Queens gambit declined d4
Knight of 6 and C captures on d5 with
ecad force on d5 and Bishop to g5 now we
have c6 strengthening the center III and
now Bishop to f5 so this is a very
pleasant way of playing this opening
choosing this line as you don't have to
worry about developing your light-square
bishop however the downside is that
white has a clear way of how to develop
so Queen f3 the bishop is unguarded so
you have to wait to the temple getting
it the g6 for example - up to g6 explain
anda now although there are some games
where h4 or Knight to h3 has been played
Bishop captures on f6 is the main line
so Queen captures we have Queen captures
G captures now now blacks pawn structure
is a little bit messed up but on the
down on the earth and jus engine still
has the bishop pair we have Knight f3
Knight to d7 and now Knights to h4 not
going after the bishop as that would
actually go in blacks favor but you want
to play g3 and get your Bishop into the
game so Bishop to e7
we have Knight to e2 now preparing to
maybe bring the other Knight to f4 as
well and now f5 asking what do you want
to do and now ok you could capture here
but then after H captures black gets a
nice semi open file for the rook this is
a very well very strong setup all the
points are on light squares the black
has a dark square bishop so this is in
fact better for black so instead we have
g3 here
allowing black double whites h-bonds as
well and this is still all considered
theory
so Bishop captures an aged forest played
G captures and the knight to f6 now and
now this position has been reached many
times maxi Marshall aggravated against
Nikita we dig of where Bishop the h3 was
played now they became in draw the with
Navarro headed against Oman Oh worship
the g2 was played and Navarro was able
to win that game and Vladimir Kramnik
heaven against Alexandra where rook the
Jimin was played and the kramnik was
able to win the game but here we have
Knight to f4 also one of the engines
favorites so you can see that a Goryeo
Tina is very well prepared for this for
this round now grabbing the h5 square if
you if you play something like Bishop to
e2 h 5 then the bishop is trapped so you
have to worry about that so Knights the
h5 offering a trade of knights also this
would activate the blacks a light square
Bishop and now there is one game where
Knights to d3 was placed to avoid the
trade but here we have King DT and it is
as a move 16 that we have a completely
new game so let's see how they how they
you know end it in in the endgame
Knight captures on f4 with ECAP resin f4
and now you can see that White's White
has two doubled points double h1 and
double F pawn but on the other hand
black has a useless light square bishop
so this Bishop is is basically a pawn
now and it's not going to be easy to get
it back into the game you can see all of
black aside from the a 7 point off all
the phones are on light squares and it's
basically the definition of a bad Bishop
so how do you play this well King to e7
with Bishop to e2 now threatening age 5
to win the bishop so h5 and now rook 81
preparing some nasty discoveries so you
should move the King King to d6 and now
Bishop to d3 we have rook 88 now
offering well trying to trade rooks all
along the e-file and he looked a3 by a
garage Akina
I rook to e3 with the idea that if rooks
are traded you can fix your pawn
structure but rook the e5 was perhaps
even better now as well it's a much more
active move you're preparing Rucker H 2
e 1 if if
is captured then you fix your bone
structure this way and you are also
already targeting the f5 bone so for the
moment you're not in actually interested
in capturing this because even if you
could win a pawn you don't really want
to trade your good bishop for for blacks
useless bishop but okay look the e3
instead with rook captures right away F
captures ending out a five with a three
and now b6 and here again you have to
decide what to play
b4 was played by guru Dakshina which is
which makes sense as you want to keep
your opponent's pawns on light squares
however this opens up the a file for for
your engine's rook
another idea is roof to g1 trying to
bring the rook over to g5 and put
pressure on the on these coupons and
this will keep a black busy for example
rook e8 a ruby g5 now attacking the pawn
King e6 Bishop e2 go after this pawn and
now you have to go rook e8 and now both
the bishop and rook are tied to the
defense of the h5 pawn and you could
maybe try and try and do something this
way although it's still very hard to
imagine how you would actually break
through here so what's one of the
options but okay now garage peanut
prefers a different one before the idea
is after the trade to play b5 so what
happens here we have a character
assembly for a character son before we
have rook to e8 that's the downside of
this of this plan it allows the black
rook to be activated and now b5 so what
would you play here we have c5 d
captures and c5 b captures and now rip
the b1 putting the rook behind the
passed pawn and now if c4 you don't
really gain anything just Bishop c2 and
you all you've done is help to white it
because you've again put your pawns on
light squares and it will only make it
easier for the white king to enter the
game especially if the black King will
have to move to help out with the
defense of the pawn it's just an easy
march for the for the for the White King
so after Luke to be one King c7 the King
will now help out with the pawn b6 check
we have King b7 and now route b5 going
after the pawns here look the ca
defending and now Bishop back to
- so we have f6 and now a very
interesting move rook - a five giving up
this pawn for for the f6 point so for
example if King characters rookie six
check King b7 you're gonna capture here
and even after rook c6 look f8 you still
don't have a way of activating your
bishop the route covers these squares
and it's still it's still a pretty bad
Bishop although it is possible but not
something you want to do so instead rook
the c6 and now rook a7 check King
captures and now rook the d7 going after
this pawn cannot be defended because the
route covers the f7 square as well so
here if you tried well c4 is is is
definitely an attempt for example if
captures then you get Bishop f7
attacking the rook rook d7 Bishop
attacks rook rook moves and now c3 would
check King c1 and now you get this
position where black already has an
advanced pawn and c3 but you might have
some problems with with the h1 and then
white will also start pushing her pawn
and well and so on but all in all not a
bad attempt for black however we have
looked the e6 instead and now rook
captures on d5 with King to c6 pushing
the rug back but now Bishop f3
threatening some nasty discoveries and
here rook d6 it's the best move and it
just shows that there are no nasty
discoveries here
so if characters captures you just trade
into a an endgame where black has a
passed pawn so here rook the d3 check
was played King to c7 and now what what
probably what the garage Gina should do
is just go captures captures and Bishop
to e2 and well play the same game it's
very unlikely that black can do anything
here since you can never move the bishop
away from the defense of the h5 pawn and
the log captures and the king wants one
spot and c3 there's really nothing to
worry about so this is one way to do it
but the choreography not wants to keep
winning chances on the board so Bishop
to d5 avoiding the trade and okay but
rook to e8 now Julian says okay now it's
time to activate the bishop since your
bishop is no longer attacking the h5
pawn king c3
now Bishop to b5 attacking the rook rook
d2 of course you will put it to a dark
square and now rook to a6 with ideas of
harassing the king the bishop and the
pawn are preventing the King from going
up the board so a few checks are more
than welcome
so Bishop to b3 stopping checks and now
Bishop back to d7 we have looked the g2
now trying to go after the pawns this
way maybe something like this although
that that's a lot of moves so Bishop to
e6 now with ideas of bringing the rook
over to a3 attacking the pin piece so
now Bishop captures an e6 rook captures
in the now comes king d3 defending the
e3 pawn we have King to d6 and now comes
Luke to g8 and okay we have King d5 at
black starts making some progress with
the King rook to b8 forcing the King
back but now rook d6 offering a trade
and now the problem is if you trade here
captures captures then the king and
ponen game is winning for black because
after Kings e4 black will always get to
the opposition for example king c6
you're gonna go king d3 king d5 and at
some point you're gonna have to move
away from the e4 square and the wild
white as well for example king c3 are
gonna go here and now even after you
defend King D to see for white we'll
have to deal with the past t1 and then
at some point you will just goggle up
all of these pawns and and win the game
easily so the King and pawn endgame is
out of the question for good actually
not so look back to c8 avoiding the
trade and now rook d7 we have looked the
a trade going after the h5 pawn and now
c4 with check king c3 and now rook to e7
going after this pawn here we have King
Tubby to and now rook back to a7
now King King will try and come down the
board and the rook will be used to give
some checks so we have rook captures on
h5 and now rook the a2 with checked with
King to c3 and here comes rook to a3
check and this is where where the magic
really happens what would you play here
just just a question now will I give you
a couple of seconds try and find a move
for
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on continuing to play
such an such a great end game and for
those who just want to enjoy the show if
you decided King bee to king c2 or king
d2 that's that's alright but if you play
king bee for what garage gonna played
that simply will not do because this
just gives a black way too much so once
again feel free to pause and punish this
king before insolence while I give you a
couple of seconds so again for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on playing a brilliant
endgame and for those who just want to
enjoy the show
so here king a rook to be three check
problem for white here is that if King
a5 just C 3 C 2 and C 1 wins the game
and if what was played in the game King
a for now the with the rook controlling
the B file the king will never be able
to join the game again
so kinky for now defending the F pawn so
what do you play here
rook the h8 of course good Regina tries
to bring the rook back into the game
rugby 7 now not allowing the King to
cross over the B file and now King b3
and the C pawn is marching forward so
rook c8 of course you want to put a rug
behind the passed pawn king d3 we have h
5 but now C 3 we have h 6 but now C 2
and here
yeah even if you try to give up this
point for somehow bringing the King
closer doesn't really work h7 rook
captures and now if King b3 going after
the point you're just gonna push the
King back rugby 7 check King has to go
back and now it's again just completely
winning so after C 2 we have kinked the
a3 and now kink the b2 now the thread is
just promotion of the of the pond so
rook to d8 check but now King captures
on e3 rook the c8 attacking the pawn
king back to d2 we have group to d8
check came to c1 and it was in this
position that Aleksandra garage cannot
resign to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so well just a
short shortly illustrate why there's
nothing to be done here even once
together we'll show the the h7 line
you're just gonna ignore the
on king b1 and next move your ear you
get a queen it doesn't matter if white
gets a queen you get a queen with
check-check and whatever you do matter
for example Queen a2 will be checkmate
and if you try something else let's say
we try King a2 to prevent King b1
doesn't really matter
rookie 7 check King b3 and now King b1
and if look the c8 you're just gonna go
Ruby 7 check King once again has to move
and now you Queen the pawn captures
captures and we are once again in a
young Gustaf's on endgame where one
player has a rook and the other doesn't
so after King c1 garage can now resign
the game and it's really really
incredible because this line always
gives a certain edge to white all from
the beginning this Bishop f5 Queen f3
going after the bishop and then this
trade should always be advantageous for
white even though it is the bishop area
playing games but this is just a
terrible Bishop so white was always
better here but the problem is it wasn't
enough to win the game in Buryatia not
kept pushing especially with that
avoiding of the of the root of the you
know a rook trade with that Bishop to d5
move and then in the end it just well
ended by by her losing the game so it
can happen tough break
especially since this is already round
10 do engine once again takes the lead
and now there are only 2 more games and
now garage Tina will really have to try
it well he already showed that she's
able to win more than one game so I
don't think it will be that big of a
deal for her but yeah it's always tough
when you're when you have the ketchup
but there are two more games do engine
in the lead and we'll see if Jo engine
will retain her watcher championship
title or will we have a new Women's
World Chess Champion so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank I ran out a Kristin Oh Esther halt
Martin bara chiton Barakat Ian and Simon
Sevilla for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
video serum thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Women's World Chess
Championship the Tata Steel masters
edition checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course the morphe
saga so thank you all I will see you
soon and
have an excellent rest of your Monday